i love you
[Music]
kourtney kardashian and travis barker
are taking their romance to new heights
literally i love you
[Music]
the love birds are on vacation in rural
utah and on tuesday
travis took to his instagram account to
share more from their dreamy getaway
and show off even more pda like
this booty on a boat moment yep
that's court lounging during a boat ride
while her man
well let's just say he's definitely
enjoying that view
in fact the pooch founder looks so good
in that teeny white bikini
the blink 182 drummer snapped this photo
of her backside
staring out at the stunning scenery i
love it
but then things escalated as they took
possibly the
sexiest nature walk in the history of
mankind
i love you check out the couple
shimmying across a narrow bridge
suspended over a huge
canyon it's enough to get your blood hot
but
if you need an extra jolt here's kravis
stealing a smooch
way up in the sky this is such a dream
come true
earlier on tuesday the keeping up with
the kardashians star shared some images
on her account
like this make out pick which scent
pulses
racing yeah there's court in the same
teeny bikini
wrapping her legs around a shirtless
travis's waist
engaging in quite the lip lock the
caption
quote just like heaven and get this
we learned kravis is into sexy scrabble
they both posted snaps of the friendly
word game travis making words like
x and orgasm while court stayed on brand
with
vegan girl and oh abcdefg
the couple who went public with their
romance earlier this year have been
enjoying
a lot of time together they recently
went on a ski trip
celebrated easter together in palm
springs and blew it out of the water for
courtney's 42nd birthday on april 18th
not only did travis surprise his lady
love with an over-the-top floral
arrangement in her home
entryway he also shared this birthday
tribute on
instagram posting this smooched up snap
their fireside cuddle sesh a corner
makeout
a pic of her legs a booty shot
some hand holding and this video
court sucking his thumb which speaks for
itself
anyways when it comes to the couple's
future things are looking bright
a source recently told et that the blink
182 drummer is quote
so in love and infatuated with the
reality star
and added that they're having the best
time together
quote he's 100 all in and totally sees a
future with her
courtney is living her best life and is
truly so happy